work I do is music um
curity psychology we did find
results when we started applying
economics and behavioral psychology to
understanding in particular privacy
decision-making when you provide
assurances about the privacy being
protected to individuals individuals
become actually less willing to provide
personal information which is a counter
interest and the reason we believe is
the cause for this phenomenon is that
people become primed to think about
privacy because when we don't realize
information we are revealing in this
information this trace of data are
pretty much continuous in a way we're
almost not equipped to act in an
efficient optimal way and in decide what
should we protect the show and what
should we should reveal so hence the
importance of the kind of research we we
try to do combined economics psychology
to really understand what people know
why they act the way they do and whether
we can try to find solutions which could
be technological solutions or policy
solutions legislation and so and so
forth or liability or incentives to in
order to direct try to direct the market
towards a more efficient outcome
you